[موسيقى]
دقيقتان
30 ثانية
[موسيقى]
130.
دقيقة واحدة
[موسيقى]
حتى
30 ثانية
جاهزة
[موسيقى]
حتى تتمكن من رؤية الهيكل
المتضمن الآن بشكل كامل ،
علمنا أن الحريق كان  تحت
السقف والآن يتم إزالة السقف بالكامل
من رجال الإطفاء الذين يتم إعاقتهم حقًا في
محاولة للسيطرة على هذا الحريق
بشكل أساسي بسبب ارتفاع
المياه وعدم القدرة على الوصول إلى الجزء
الداخلي من المنزل بسبب
قضبان السطو وجميع الإجراءات الأمنية
الموجودة في هذا المنزل
بالقرب من تقاطع النصب
التذكاري وكيركوود وتعطيك فكرة
عما يتعاملون به مع
الماء حتى أفخاذهم حتى
وسطهم
عليهم الوقوف فقط
لأنهم لا يستطيعون  الوصول إلى
صنابير إطفاء الحرائق ، كيف ترى صنبور إطفاء الحرائق
هنا ، لقد قاموا
بتوصيل اثنين منهم ولكن كما يمكنك أن تقول أن
رجال الإطفاء في وضع دفاعي نوعًا ما في
الوقت الحالي ، ما عليك سوى مشاهدة
هذا الشيء وهو
يرتفع ويحاول الاحتفاظ به  من sp  القراءة
لمنازل أخرى حتى أنهم قاموا
بتشغيل هذا السلم الجوي هنا وكما
ترون
ضغط الماء منخفض قادم منه في
محاولة لمنع الأشجار
من الاشتعال ولكن حريق كبير
هنا على الجانب الغربي من المدينة بالقرب من
النصب
التذكاري وكيركوود ،
شكرًا لك
[  موسيقى]
[موسيقى]
نعم سيدتي ،
لا يمكنني الحصول على عنوان قد أكون قادرًا
على إيصالك إلى الشوارع التي تدور حول هذا الموضوع
إنه
جالس هنا في الزاوية ، مايك أليس كذلك
تذكر ما
كانت عناوين الشوارع تلك هي الشوارع المتقاطعة ،
دعك ترى أن
أحد الشوارع هو جناح أبيض
أنا أعمل عليه في وضع الاستعداد ،
سنحاول القدوم إلى هنا
إذا كان بإمكاني حتى رؤيته والعنوان
سأفعل  من الأفضل أننا حصلنا على
أشجار في الطريق
[موسيقى
] لا أرى عنوانًا في المنزل ،
أنا متأكد من وجود عنوان ولكن
لا يمكنني رؤيته ،
آه يا جيسون ، هل تراقبني يا جي
ون نحن في الأسفل  400 رطل من الوقود
مما يعني أننا نعلم أننا بحاجة إلى البدء في
القلق بشأن أه
وقتنا الذي نقضيه مهما كان ما
تريدني أن أفعله  ستفعل
لكن الوقود سيصبح مشكلة هنا
قبل وقت طويل
[موسيقى]
نعم مايك
لا ، نحن بخير
[موسيقى]
ولكن ليس في الوقت الحالي أنا في انتظار
رد منه
[موسيقى]
لا نحن "  نحن جيدون الآن وأه نعم
يمكنك إعطائنا
ضربة أخرى يعتمد ذلك على ما يخبرنا به جيسون
هنا
أننا نحاول إدارة وقودنا في الوقت المناسب ،
لذا حسنًا ، لقد فهمت ذلك ، لذا قال
إننا سنبقى هنا
حتى نضطر إلى المغادرة للحصول على الوقود ، لذلك نحن بخير ،
سأكون جاهزًا لك في
غضون ثلاث دقائق
[موسيقى]
30 ثانية
[موسيقى
] حسنًا
[موسيقى]
جيدة
حسنًا ، ما حدث هو أن السقف بأكمله
متورط الآن ، وستكون
هذه خسارة
تامة ، وقد ذهب رجال الإطفاء إلى الوقوف حقًا من
خلال التأكد من عدم
انتشاره إلى أي من الهياكل الأخرى
الموجودة هنا ،
والحمد لله على أنه لطيف  من
العزلة توجد بعض المنازل الريفية القريبة
من الأشياء التي لاحظتها
وربما يمكنك رؤيتها من
الصورة هنا
هو أن الشجرة الموجودة بجوار
المنزل قد اشتعلت فيها النيران الآن
[موسيقى]
توقف رجال الإطفاء عن صب
الماء
عليها آه ، سيتعين عليهم ترك نفسها
تحترق لأن
جهود مكافحة الحرائق لا تعمل فقط ، حيث
تمنع قضبان السطو
رجال الإطفاء من
ادخل إلى داخل الهيكل الذي
حاولت في الأصل إطفاء النيران من
خلال النوافذ الذي لم
يكن ناجحًا ، يمكنك فقط أن ترى أن
هذه خسارة كاملة إلى حد كبير
يواصل رجال الإطفاء اختراق
المياه هنا ، وهذا أحد الأشياء
التي
حذرنا العمدة من حقيقة
أنك تعرف أن الخدمات محدودة للغاية عندما
يتعلق الأمر بالمدينة ومحاولة مكافحة
الحرائق أو الذهاب إلى حالات الطوارئ
أو طلب مساعدة الشرطة لأنهم
لا يستطيعون الوصول إلى
هنا ، فالمياه هنا تأتي من بوفالو
بايو والتي  كما نعلم جميعًا ،
غمرت المياه بشكل خاص بين الطريق السريع 6
على طول الطريق هنا إلى الحلقة
وهذه المنطقة من النصب التذكاري
تستوعب قدرًا كبيرًا من
رجال الإطفاء الذين يقفون في عمق الخصر
الماء هنا ،
إنهم يقفون نوعًا ما من
خلال التأكد من أن الحريق
لا ينتشر ، لذا فإن
الخسارة الكاملة هنا بالقرب من
منطقة كيركوود تعود إليكم يا رفاق
[موسيقى]
شكرًا لك
جيسون
[موسيقى]
أعلم  من المحتمل أنك تعرف
هذا بالفعل ولكننا نشك جميعًا في أن هذا
الحريق قد تم
إشعاله على الأرجح من قبل صاحب المنزل
لأنه ربما لا يمتلك مايك تأمينًا ضد الفيضانات
ولا يتحدث فقط إلى الشرطة الأخرى
عبر الراديو
وهم مقتنعون تمامًا
هذه حريق
قد يكون قصة في حد ذاته أشخاص تعرفهم
نوعًا ما يائسًا مثل ذلك المنزل الذي كان معروضًا
للبيع هناك
في خزان خشب السرو باركر الذي
صورناه ، أعتقد أنه كان بالأمس أو
قبل يوم من اشتعال النيران مثل
هذا
لأنه لا يوجد سبب
لوقوع حريق في المنزل عندما لا يكون لديك أي شيء
قيد التشغيل ،
دعني أتحقق من ذلك مع مايك
لمدة 30 دقيقة ، فهذا
سيدفعه لذلك فأنا لست متأكدًا تمامًا من
عدم وجود طريقة لمعرفة  أم في  في هذه
النقطة ،
نحافظ على أكبر قدر ممكن من الوقود
ولكن سيتعين علينا فقط تشغيلها عن طريق الأذن
[موسيقى
] بعد أن نظرنا إليها ، أعني أنها
ليست بقدر ما اعتقدت أنها
تسمح لي برؤية ما إذا كنا  يمكن أن تجد
شيئًا من هذا القبيل أو ما شابه
ذلك هنا
، لا بأس
[موسيقى]
جايسون سننتقل إلى
جنوب غرب هيوستن حيث أعلم أنه
كان هناك بعض الفيضانات إذا كان هذا مناسبًا
لك
لدي شعور بأننا ذاهبون إلى
تجد ما نبحث عنه هناك
[موسيقى]
أنت